it can swallow entire gazelles
turtles
and even lions
this is the nile crocodile the most
dangerous crocodile in the world
it normally preys on animals found in
africa but now
it's coming for you
how easy would it be for this crocodile
to swallow you
what secrets lie in the crocodile's
stomach
and how would its heart help digest you
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you were swallowed by a
crocodile
if you think something like this is
impossible think again
crocodile attacks are more common than
shark attacks
and these attacks are responsible for
nearly 1 000 fatalities a year
so what would happen if you were one of
these attacks
would you be able to survive
first let's get to know a little bit
more about this creature who's coming
after you
the nile crocodile is typically found in
africa but has also been seen in florida
in the united states
these crocodiles are incredibly
aggressive and are responsible for over
300 attacks on people every year
what might make it so aggressive is its
size
the nile crocodile can grow up to six
meters long and weigh up to
550 kilograms
all this combined makes it the most
dangerous crocodile on earth
and now
it's coming to swallow you whole
[Music]
you'd first get attacked by the
crocodile somewhere along a river and
it's likely this would happen between
december and may since that's the
crocodile's breeding season
as you're walking along the river the
crocodile would stalk you waiting for
the perfect opportunity to attack you
probably wouldn't even notice the croc
and even if you did it might be hard to
get away from it as the nile croc can
run up to 18 kilometers per hour on land
and as it caught up to you it would
strike at your leg with its massive jaw
applying 3 500 kilograms of pressure
this would break your leg preventing you
from getting away
and now the crocodile could drag you
into the river
where it likes to do the rest of its
eating
now that you're in the water with the
crocodile biting into your leg it would
begin to roll you around in the water
this is it attempting to disorient and
drown you
and at this point you'd be passed out
and now that you're not moving
the nile croc would swallow your body
whole
you would pass through the crocodile's
esophagus and into its stomach
but wait
this is a lot of food and not every
animal would be able to eat something
like this so
how can the crocodile
well the crocodile stomach is unique
that's because these creatures swallow
rocks to help break up their food
and that's why the crocodile didn't need
to chew you
while you're inside the crocodile
stomach you'd be smushed by all these
rocks
and with that your body would be broken
up into smaller chunks
and rocks aren't the only thing that
would help the croc digest you
inside the crocodile's body
is a heart valve that they control with
their nerves
instead of this valve going to the
crocodile's lungs
it goes to the stomach this allows the
crocodile to produce 10 times more
gastric acid than most other animals
over the course of a week your body
would be getting crushed up by all these
rocks and you'd be getting dissolved by
all the stomach acid
skin bones
hair and all
then the crocodile would poop out your
remains and go hunting for its next
victim
so the next time you're near a swampy
river watch out for crocodiles
if you're not careful they can be pretty
dangerous
but
there are some things you should be even
more afraid of
they're the largest snakes on earth
roaming the amazon
they've eaten goats deer and even
crocodiles
so what would happen if an anaconda
tried to eat you
can an anaconda really swallow a human
how long would you be traveling through
the snake's body
and has something like this happened
before
this is what if
and here's what would happen if you were
swallowed by an anaconda
believe it or not in 2014 someone was
actually dumb enough to attempt this
he was wearing a large bulky suit
covered in pig's blood
the anaconda worked for an hour wrapping
its mouth around the head of the suit
but it was ultimately unsuccessful in
swallowing the human hole
if it had been successful
how would an anaconda be able to eat a
full-sized adult
so you happen to be wandering in the
amazon rainforest and you stumble upon
one of these giant anacondas
green anacondas grow up to 9 meters in
length and can weigh as much as 225
kilograms
you might think you'd be a tasty meal to
them as a small meal for an anaconda is
about 18 kilograms if they were to
gobble you up it would keep them
satisfied for weeks
but a meal over 45 kilograms like you
might not be what an anaconda is most
interested in
due to how massive you are not to
mention being taller and broader than
most animals it eats
you would take too long to consume
this in turn would leave the anaconda
vulnerable to predators for weeks if not
months until it finishes digesting you
but let's say it did want to eat you
what would happen then
well before an anaconda swallows you it
would kill you first
an anaconda is a constrictor snake and
it kills by wrapping its body all around
its prey and quickly crushing them to
death with over nine thousand pounds of
pressure
it would be a pretty quick end for you
but we all know that's not how this show
works
so
let's assume you survived this and we
get to see the entire process
the anaconda would then widen its jaw to
swallow you whole
you won't have to worry about it chewing
you up into little bits since it only
has fangs used for holding its prey
and luckily as opposed to other snakes
the anaconda isn't venomous so its fangs
won't poison and paralyze you but
something you will find in the
anaconda's mouth is lots and lots of
saliva
yeah this will be used to moisten you
you know so it's easier for the anaconda
to slide you down their gullet
so now you're moving down the snake's
esophagus
as with many other animals the muscles
in the esophagus will push you down the
snake's body
the anaconda also has the ability to
move and bend its ribs to crush you even
further and push you down into its
stomach
okay now you're in the anaconda stomach
don't worry we're still keeping you
alive you know to make this more fun
the anaconda stomach produces powerful
acids and stomach enzymes that will
dissolve your skin
and then eventually your bones
how fast do these acids work exactly
well an anaconda once dissolved an
alligator's skin in just three days so
your squishy fleshy skin would disappear
pretty quickly
your body would break down even further
as you move through the snake's small
intestine
that's due to the liver and pancreas
secreting even stronger enzymes
everything besides your hair and your
nails would be digested at this point
and even if you were wearing some
magical suit that protected you from the
acid and everything else it would still
be a couple of weeks before you were
unceremoniously pooped out
so it's likely you'd starve
although something like this is
incredibly unlikely
just leave anacondas alone
after all they aren't interested in
eating you in most cases as you're just
too big
but don't cheer up just yet because what
would come after you next would not be
spooked by your size
oh no no no no
something is lurking in the water
do you see it
close calls like this happen with whales
more often than you might expect
and although the people in these videos
got away relatively unscathed
there's no denying that they were just
meters away from being a whale's lunch
[Music]
but what would happen if they hadn't
been so lucky
could a human body survive being
swallowed by a whale
has it ever happened before
[Music]
this is what if
and here's what would happen if you were
swallowed by a whale
if you've never seen a whale up close
it's hard to comprehend just how
monstrous they can really be
to put it in perspective the blue whale
is the largest animal on the planet
its tongue alone weighs as much as an
elephant and it can fit anywhere between
400 and 500 people in its mouth
but we wouldn't have to worry about one
of these guys swallowing us anytime soon
because their anatomy makes it nearly
impossible
instead we should be more concerned with
their smaller cousins sperm whales
in 1891
reports emerged that a man had been
swallowed by one of these whales
and although he lived to tell the tale
he would never be the same again
according to the story james bartley was
swallowed when a whale attacked his ship
and he wasn't retrieved until the
following day
when the crew found and killed the whale
they quickly brought it on board their
ship and cut it open revealing an
unconscious but very alive james bartley
his face and arms were bleached white
and he was blind all thanks to the
stomach acids of the whale
however as the years went by people
started poking holes in this story and
questioned whether james had really been
swallowed by a whale
i mean wouldn't the stomach acids do
more damage than just bleaching his skin
well with the power of science we took a
closer look
and we quickly discovered that if you
get swallowed by a whale
coming back out with shiny white skin
would be the least of your worries
okay so the first thing you'd have to
worry about once you were swallowed
would be getting shredded to pieces by
the sperm whale's impressive set of
teeth
each tooth is approximately 20
centimeters long
that's about the length of an average
chef knife and whales have anywhere from
40 to 50 of these
let's say you're lucky enough to make it
past all of them
next you'd begin your descent down the
throat
not only would it be dark and slimy down
here but you'd also find it hard to
breathe due to the lack of oxygen and an
increase in methane gas
as the whale's throat muscles
constricted in and out to help force you
down you'd also start to feel
hydrochloric acid beginning to eat away
at your skin
i know what you're thinking we just got
into this whale and james bartley's
story already seems pretty fishy
well you're not wrong but what would be
the fun in stopping now
so next you'd be dropped into the first
and largest of the whale's four stomachs
you'd probably be in there for a while
but on the bright side you might have
some light in the form of a
bioluminescent squid or two being
gnoshed on after your arrival sperm
whales love neon flying squid
you'd better enjoy this brief light show
because after this you'd just be tossed
from one stomach to the next
with the acids breaking down almost all
of your body until you're just a bunch
of bones being unceremoniously ejected
from the whale's anus
so yeah it's pretty safe to say that
there's no way you could be swallowed
whole by a whale and live to tell the
tale
sorry james you may have been able to
fool people in the 1890s but we're onto
you now
as vast as they are and as monstrous as
they might seem to us
whales actually have no interest in
eating humans
and if they could talk they would
probably make a point of telling us that
but that's a topic for another what if
you